This episode of "Shots
of Awe" is brought you
by the Toyota Prius.
Let's lead the way.
In biology when
there's a mutation,
and that mutation is
expressed in the organism,
and it turns out to
improve that organisms
capacities to survive.
Then that ends up
being a good idea.
That organism will
replicate more widely
than others and that
idea will spread.
That's biological evolution.
Now with cultural evolution,
we went from trading
in genes that were
good ideas to trading
in memes that hopefully
are good ideas.
We've also empowered
individuals all over the world
to disseminate their means
at the speed of light.
This makes us
crucial players now
in what's going to
happen in the future.
Like we are now the
number one replicators
of ideas that can
transform the world.
And we've usurped
biological evolution
with this cultural evolution.
The membrane of mind that
has overcome the planet
is one in which ideas are
literalized through technology,
through transformation,
through all the things
that mankind has done
as a force of geology.
So ideas matter.
So what are the
ideas that are you
are going to spread
into the world?
What are you going
to pay forward?
What is the possibility?
What are the good vibes?
What are the grand
visions that you
are going to utter
into the ethersphere,
into the mindsphere?
And this something
that all of us
should be thinking about
every single time we
tweet or share or
post or publish.
We're co-writing
the future story.
We decide what happens.